[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar cosmic combining expert curation
with scientific innovation in a gold
standard database for precision oncology
i am marie stone of lab roots and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by kaiogen to learn more visit
kayagen.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
i'd like to now welcome our speakers dr
bislaw sondhka senior scientist cosmic
catalog of somatic mutations in cancer
welcome sanger
and rebecca white scientific
communications manager cosmic catalog of
somatic mutations in cancer welcomes
senior dr sanka rebecca you may now
begin your presentation
thanks so much so i'm going to kick off
um we have just a bit of a description
of why cosmic um what you know why
cosmic exists
what we do and how we do it and then i'm
going to hand over to this floor to talk
about um a bit more about our products
and how you can get the most value from
them
so starting with the why
um we exist to accelerate the
advancement of cancer research be that
diagnosis treatment or prevention and
ultimately we do that to improve the
length and quality of life for all
cancer patients
our vision is that one day a patient
will go into a doctor's surgery and as
soon as they hear a doctor say to them
i'm sorry you have cancer it's followed
up immediately by the words but it's
okay we know exactly what to do about
this and exactly what your treatment
journey will be um
what do we do within that context well
we collate streamline and quality filter
global cancer somatic mutation data we
make that data useful and easy to
understand and we draw out salient
insights
the idea is that our database will
accelerate research without compromising
on quality
and exactly how we do that is through
expert curation data interpretation and
visualization
we're experts in identifying data
extracting it standardizing it and
presenting it
now i'll go into a bit more detail on
this later so don't worry about the
notes here and i just wanted to kind of
start with that why i'm positioning
ourselves within cancer research
so as many of you will know
cancers are no longer thought of as one
single disease it can be thought of as a
group of diseases that share common
characteristics characteristics that
give them advantage and abnormal
behaviors that help them to grow and
thrive and these are really nicely
described through the hallmarks of
cancer
excitingly the hallmarks also represent
really good strategies for tackling
cancers
if you can take away things like their
ability to grow vasculature and their
food sources if you could get immune
cells to recognize the cancers or if you
could somehow stop the cancers from
growing and spreading that would be a
really good way of stopping things
but it's a bit more complicated we know
that obviously there's not one single
mechanism by which tumors and cancers
achieve these things and they do it in
multiple different ways
and sometimes even if you tackle one
aspect there might be a redundant
mechanism where cancers are doing it in
multiple ways and i'll come into more on
this later and why it's important in the
context of somatic mutations
um and of course we also need to think
about cancer on lots of different levels
of biological organization um in terms
of the environment and what sort of
musicians are exposed to to the body and
how all of our bodies are slightly
different through to the actual
environment microenvironment and
specific tissue differences to the
cellular level and what's going on there
to the proteins and their dysfunction in
dysregulation and finally down to
somatic mutations or mutations in the
genes and all of these changes
participate in the development of the
disease but it starts with our genes
and that's why somatic mutations are so
important they help us to understand the
bigger picture
through analysis of somatic mutations
we're able to link dna change to protein
dysfunction we're then able to associate
those known functions of the protein
with biological processes and
identifying the pathways and processes
involved in disease progression
again this is important because if we
think back to the fact that you can get
resistance or certain treatments in
isolation don't work that's because a
couple a few mutations if you look at
them might be impacting multiple
pathways which gives the cancer the same
ability to maybe grow uncontrollably so
you need to think about how you can
target multiple pathways
and then choose an optical therapy
regime or propose a new therapy regime
or in fact tell a patient we don't we
know this treatment won't work saving
months of unnecessary treatments
and finally it's unpicking the etiology
of cancer if you can combine mutations
with information about things like
environment you can begin to understand
what's causing cancers for individuals
now so in the ideal world what we have
is
genetic information linked to the cancer
information linked to treatment
information
but again another challenge is there's
just too much data and there's not
enough time
in 2020 alone there were more than 30
000 publications that linked cancer and
mutations
um and that's just way too much for any
single person to keep up to date with
and they're still missing information we
don't know exactly which mutations are
driving cancer the functions of the
products of those mutations or which
mutations could be good candidates for
drug development we know some of it but
not all of it
and we also end up working in niches and
focusing on say a specific cancer type
or a specific protein type so what you
need is a big database that collates all
of this you can begin to see the
patterns across cancer types across
mutation types and how maybe one
treatment may be applicable in lots of
different types of these diseases
um
so as i said that data becomes useful
once collated standardized and
structured so the insights can be
extracted and that's exactly what cosmic
does and what we're experts at and in
fact we've been experts for 20 years um
we started out in 2002 at the sanger
institute that's before the human genome
project was even completed um it's a
spreadsheet of the sanger institute's
cancer genome project to keep track of
genetic mutations and it started out as
just four genes b raf hras k-raz and
enraz just 67 000 samples and 10 000
mutations it was so useful it's been
grown and it's sustained to today we
include all genes more than 1.5 million
samples and 23.4 million mutations are
recorded our data resolution
um is unparalleled and our experience is
unparalleled and that's why we are the
gold standard database
so how exactly do we go about doing this
well this is kind of a broad summary we
gather data from high quality and
trusted resources worldwide
mainly this is scientific literature but
we also get data from some of the wider
cancer genome consortiums and data from
some smaller studies and more recently
we've also been getting data from
clinicaltrials.gov and other clinical
trial resources
in our actionability product
we combine all the data and we run it
through a large standardization and
quality control pipeline and map it to
other existing resources and use those
to annotate our data such as ensembl
and then that is then produced into a
range of products uh the most common one
is our download file um but then we also
have a suite of data visualization and
data interpretation tools which uh will
be gone into in more detail later but
i'm going to spend a bit more time
focusing on where our data comes from
so
we have um two broadly two different
types we have these this broad genomic
data and that's as i said comes from
these uh from semi automation annotation
of the big genome screens um and also
um genome-wide studies that are
published in the scientific literature
and we take the supplementary data
sheets and run them through genic
annotation systems and then all of that
is mapped to both human genome assembly
37 and 38 and you can toggle between
both on our website or download data on
both
but our real kind of area of expertise
is in manual curation i said earlier
that we were first formed in 2002 and we
still have some of that curation
expertise from when we were first formed
in the team and being passed down um our
curators are postdoc level experts who
just they have brilliant expertise in
being able to extract data and
high-quality data from publications and
it's not just
um the gene data they also extract data
on things like cancer type and stage and
also some kind of wider clinical
metadata around sex age family history
prior treatments certain environmental
factors
as well as the mutation status and
sample source
and this deep genic data isn't random it
actually comes from our cancer gene
census so the cancer gene census is
currently
729 genes which are known to have um to
be drivers of cancer and that's um the
literature proves that they have a
mechanistic role in driving cancer
forward there's tier 1 and tier 2 genes
again this will be discussed in a little
bit um
but those genes are where we focus our
gene curation because we know they are
the relevant genes and it removes some
of the noise of irrelevant things but we
also have disease specific curation so
each release our curators will focus on
a specific disease and usually this is
rare cancers last release it was
metaplastic mesoplastic breast cancer
and other cancers of the female genital
tract
and this release will be head and neck
cancer now what's interesting about the
disease curation is through reading all
those papers our curators identify new
genes that should be put forward as
candidates for the cancer gene census
because they're
the role in cancer they're seeing in
these papers
um and then that gets handed over to our
cancer gene census expert who will then
validate or invalidate and then add that
gene either as tier one or tier 2 to our
census so in our upcoming release in v96
in may 2022
um we have a focus on head and neck
cancers
which account for three and five percent
of the uh u.s and european cancer
incidents um rather than focusing
broadly on on all head and neck cancers
they've done a specific focus in on the
rare reforms of head and neck cancer
those that affects library glands
sinuses or muscle and bone in the head
and neck
um that data has come from 56
publications and this is a really nice
example where a prkd1
a serine threonine kinase was added to
the cancer gene census as a tier 2 gene
because it was found to have a role in
cribiform adenocarcinomas
um
so this is just to show how all of our
data links together um and then the end
outcome in terms of pure stats is what
you're seeing here um we have a total of
currently 23 million mutations
from 1.5 million samples 20 out there 28
000 papers and 39 000 wgs samples
and we also record things like copy
number variants fusions differentially
methylated cpgs and gene expression
variants so now i'm going to hand over
for a more detailed look at our products
and how you can use them
thank you very much rebecca
so
uh
that was an overview of the whole
database now
will tell you a little bit about how
this data can be used in
uh
in real life
you are all aware that there are many
different types of cancer
one of the most common
cancers is the lung cancer
and 85 percent of all lung cancer are
usually non-small cell lung cancers they
are rarely diagnosed before they become
metastatic
and they are
major cause of cancer more mortality
so what cosmic data can show can tell us
about uh
about
lung cancer what genes and what
dysfunction are most difficult for this
subtype of cancer
from this list you can see that
three more frequently dated genes in
this type of cancer are egfr keras and
tp53 so that's the first information we
have these three genes that are
potentially causing cancer and
potentially can be targeted
if you go deeper into the data we of
course see much more
okay
this is a known oncogene and uh on this
slide you can see the distribution of
mutations increasingly in lag
concentrations across these units you
can immediately see that practically all
mutations are focused around this
one
uh spot which is glycine 12
and this is typical pattern for an
oncogene which suggests
this is a
typical foreign because it's
much more hard
to
bring
to to to cause the gene to to be more
active than to just destroy its function
so in this case very precise change is
required and this is what we can see in
cancer populations
uh
going deeper into that you can see what
is the composition of this mutations
that affect uh mostly these two uh amino
acids uh 12 and
13.
so you can see there are different
consequences and you can see that within
even within the same codon not all
nucleotides are
equally affected so
one of the reasons of that situation is
the limitation of
the genetic code so only certain
changes bring selective
bring bring this
desired change that actually drives
counter there
and the other reason is
what factors are actually irresponsible
for mutations
you can see a
comparison between
lung cancer and colorectal
adenocarcinoma on amino acid level
is exactly the same change
but you can see that on the dna level
most fruit transmutations are slightly
different and this is caused by the
different exposure to environmental
factors
in lung cancer the major factor is
tobacco smoke which results in
mostly
g2t changes
while in colorectal adrenal carcinoma
this may come for example for from
heterocyclic amines
and the result is mostly g2a still
on the
level and on the on the protein level
the change is exactly the same and the
same consequence
increasing proliferation
of cancer cells
another gene
has slightly different function p53 this
is a classic tumor suppressor key
you can see that pattern of mutations in
that gene is slightly different they are
spread
uh more evenly across the whole gene
body
and especially uh at the bottom track
insertions and missions you can see lots
of mutations are there and many of them
results with a
frame shift or truncating
anybody
happen
they
just break totally the function of tumor
suppressor gene which cannot protect the
cell from
oncogenic transformation
and
these are
against
this mutations that result in nonsense
substitution
or
french
before
it ends and
it's
not active in the cell
then set of the g to gfrs again
as you can see here
very nicely focused peaks of
mistransmutations cannot function
but in this case they are not
tested just in one place right
in case of k-ras
but we have several categories
of 10 function mutations and
knowing about this mutations is quite
important because they are actually used
to
to
design specific drugs that
act
against forms mutated forms of this
protein
and are more or less
selective
so an example is mutation t790m
which
has a truck designed to act against it
was immerging it
then we have another cluster of
mutations in that gene which are
in this case not
simple substitutions but
insertions and divisions but
it's different between these mutations
and mutations we have seen in 2052 is
that these are inferent
in those so that means that the sequence
of the protein after mutation is changed
and only small fragment of the gene
is
added or removed without changing the
main function of the gene
but with changing the control mechanisms
that uh are normally protecting protein
from being
hyperactive
uh
i mentioned
t790m
the hp permutations is quite important
mutation because it makes lung cancer
resistant to
some of the precision oncology drugs
and
they are also
arising as a result of competing
it occurs predominantly under the
therapeutical regime and after
this drug is removed
from the body uh then this mutations
tends to disappear so this creates an
opportunity to precisely
design the therapeutic regime
to control
occurrence of these mutations but you
need to know that this mutation is
occurring or not
and to to be control of that
process
okay
excuse me i just got message that my
sound is not very well i'll try to
disappear to
improve the quality
uh so that was
the lung cancer but of course the
much more types of cancer in cosmic and
you can see
similar data for all of them
and i would like to explain how we can
compare different cancers
and
in this case i'll start with a
hematologic neoplasms
you have three
major subtypes here acute myeloid female
myelo dysplastic syndrome and my low
proliferative neoplasts
and
these are very general
types of blood cancers and
you can see that already on that level
the gene sets are slightly different but
of course you can go deeper so that
gives you this high resolution of
phenotypes
you can check the set of genes which is
specific
for
certain cancer
type so
if we compare
go deeper and compare myeloproliferative
neoplasts
we can see
different rare cancer types and i would
like to focus especially on mast cell
neoplast this is very
rare cancer
most of us
see them only once or twice in their
careers
and interesting
thing about this
type of cancer is that uh the relevant
driver of this disease is kid
which is an encoding and this oncogene
is known from a non-blood cancer
which is
in this case cultural interests from
from ultimate exactly this the same gene
is responsible for
development of two different cancer
types
but when you have a look at the
mutational profiles within these two
diseases you can see
the differences in case of not so
neoplasm it's mostly prostate
transferase domain
that is affected in case of
gastrointestinal stromal tumor
these are mostly mutations that affect
the juxta membrane domain and that shows
you again how different
tissues
development of different cancer types
even though it's the same gene
not uh not always the change that
causes this thing to drive cancer is the
same this is very important to know
again to
design diagnostic
tests
to
interpret variants of unknown
significance
and
to identify
pharma target for precision oncology
so this this is about
somatic mutations simple somatic
musicians but of course uh there are
other
uh
changes
to the dna that can drive concern
gene fusions are a famous example of
that
cosmic has a resource that currently
describes uh
305 chambers and this is again
manufactured so the quality is
priority here
and
you can explore gene fusions as well
so
just to summarize this with all these
data we can identify
typical for each currency type and
with signature type
then to certain degree just by looking
at the patterns of
somatic mutations we can predict their
impact is kind of functional loss of
function are we talking about tumor
suppressor gene or oncogene
and then
we can find some clues about the origin
of mutations
caused by tobacco smoke or is it
but
contrary to what it says
here
they actually don't answer
thousands
of genes and
millions of mutations thrive cancer and
why so something very it does
but typically
uh when we have a cancer sample we have
thousands of limitations there
so look
looking for for
these very few mutations that are
actually matter there is quite
complicated
then
it doesn't answer the question which
mutations therapist opportunity and
which makes the therapy ineffective
then
another interesting question is how we
can better determine what mechanics
drive cancer
and
for example genomic instability
and a cosmic has
several
products that are built on top of the
main database
rebecca already mentioned the oldest
cancer gene sensors
and cancer gene sensors is manually
created resource
that
gathers genes which will have very good
evidence that they are involved in
cancer
driving processes
and
what to do we not only
choose our protein cancer but we also
say how and
this is another resource within cancer
gene senses hallmarks of cancer so again
homeworks of cancer tell you which
biological processes are
uh disturbed in cancer cells so for
example is it a
dna repair that is damaged is it
uh
proliferation
is it apoptosis
and
it just describes in terms of
hormones of cancer and uh
manually curated information tells you
very briefly
what
all marx does gene is involved in so for
example tp53
is involved in
control of apoptosis you can find it on
these pages for averaging and
links to uh to the source of this
information you can go straight to
pubmed um
so that was configuring sensors sorry i
didn't change the slide
and
of course it's not only about rotation
so another thing is that
uh all we're talking about for mutations
they describe
this function
uh
but
nubis genes are also changed through a
differential expression and cosmic has
these
differential expression variants too
and you can see in this example that
apc which is known tumor suppressor gene
very important in colorectal cancer
where it is usually
affected by inactivating mutations in
ovarian cancer is mostly
regulated on the expression level so for
the same gene and different cancers you
can see also different ways this
gene is
affected
and then one of the questions was
if you identify the right mutations what
can you do
about this mutation to help patients and
to address that question we have created
another manually curated resource
cosmic action ability
where rich mutation and cancer type
we are
curating uh all the drugs
that
can be used for
that are
doing
a virus at the moment so basically it
covers the current state of precision
oncology
and
to help navigate into this resource we
introduced
different uh actionability
ranks uh with first one tracks are
already on the market and approved
but also
uh we present drugs which are in late
phases
of clinical trials and met primary
objectives
also drugs in trials we
put
primary objectives reached
and
we add some case studies
this resource is updated four times a
year
so
all the data that we provide there are
quite up to date
uh
as for the sources for actionability uh
we use uh technical database records but
around half of the data are actually
coming from additional data sources
like literature so
many of the clinical trial results are
not being updated in the clinical trials
database
but
instead the results are published in the
literatures we look for that and we
integrate
they first
give the most comprehensive
also if the trial
terminated
we aim to
because some it's not part of the
efficacy of the drug
it can be business reason and in such
cases if it's good
for people to know
that this has happened and this drug
actually still can be potentially
potentially good
so this is the summary at the moment we
have uh
almost 50
genes
fully curated
over 200 genes are mentioned there this
resource is
under constant development and as i said
priority for us is to keep it
up to date
at all times
then of course i already mentioned
certain mutations result in
resistance to certain therapies and
cosmic does gather information about
about such mutations
so
patients that bring resistance to
particular
which mutations
should be
monitored and then the therapy can be
changed
customization sensors another
product
tells which of the thousands mutations
actually matter uh
in this example you can see numerous
you know
i was talking about before
and uh
transmutation sensors uses different
biochemical
parameters and properties
manufactured information
and with certain algorithms
like the nds for example that measures
uh the selective pressure that acts on
certain
amino acids in cancer samples and by
integrating
this is mostly
again
g12 g13 and
n61
and
all this information is
clearly presented so we propose our
whole ranking for the mutations but
and you have all the components of the
data that you use to create that ranking
scrutinize for yourself and to
to
work out your own ranking if you are not
happy with ours on the mutation level
every
of the
five millions of coding mutations in
cosmic is described with all these
values
and we have of course
statistics cosmic across
all the diseases so you can see what
frequency this variant has in
every disease you can see
uh
clean bar information if anything
has been manually curated by this
apparently it's known as cancer
uh driving so we focus only on cancer
specific annotations from pinbar
on the other hand uh variants that are
to be uh
frequently seen in normal populations as
german variants are like to drive
uh enhancers
we use nomad database to provide
frequency across all populations are not
high
check every variant against
this information here plus
dmds
if
certain variant has positive dnds score
in
a certain cancer
then we report it here
ep53 that i mentioned before as a
classic
tumor suppressor gene
you can see three spikes of peruvian
mutations
which as i said are typical for
oncogenes
and
that is very interesting case because
tp53 is known as
a handbook example of tumor suppressor
gene
so what these three peaks do
cosmic 3d another tool that we have is
helping answering this question because
even though you have three distinct
peaks on the
gene length
when you
project these mutations on the 3d
structure of the protein you can see
that
with this red
color
they all re-cluster in the 3d space
around the sides that bind
that tp-53 used to bind to dna and they
change the affinity of tp53 to dna and
they are in fact
kind of functional patients
give
that tp53 slightly different function
and instead of preventing cancer it
actually
in certain cases
drives it
another
example is egfr and another feature of
cosmic 3d
we can we can see difference between
wild type and mutated amino acid
and
here
with the orange
you can see the mutant protein
and
with the pink you can see the wild type
protein i see that
better
on that figure
but the orange
the orange space actually invades the
space occupied by the small molecule
drug
and
that
shows
the mechanism of truck
resistance
in egfr
when the slides
mentioned before
the difference between uh
exposure to different mutagens uh we can
see the result of that on the dna level
but is there anything more
we can tell about it and in fact there
is
cosmic also presents
mutational signatures
it is a very
useful thing because you don't need to
do any additional experiments basically
you take the
next sequencing result for a
patient sample
and you analyze
uh
single nucleotide substitutions with
their surroundings
and then you see which
types of alterations have what frequency
you end up with a histogram you can see
on the right here
that shows you that
in this
in this sample you have
quite a lot of c2g changes and
that's the first stage
this is your
mutagon
then we can use
from the convolutional algorithms to
identify patterns typical for different
metagenic factors so
the mutational profile
then is
the convoluted
into
the nutritional signals that allow you
for identification of mutagens
that were causing
the mutational process
within the within the sample
custom has a cut loop
signature
explorer and then you can compare
signatures in your samples with
signatures in cosmic catalog
this is still ongoing and growing and we
are adding
new signatures but they are
uh again manually curated and only when
they are accepted by the
uh
by the scientists working on it we add
it to cut to our catalog so it's quite
conservative and you can use these
signatures
they are something
you can compare with other people
particular application of
the signature concept
there is significant that
is typical for the damage of
uh homologous recombination repair
and
in this case uh it's
you can of course
c
mutation in bracket one
uh
not about looking mutations in g
looking for mutations in genes involved
in that
this is measuring the effect so it
doesn't matter if the
damage of the hormone
occurs through
mutation or through changes in
expression we should see gyms can be
applied
so
all these data are available are
available
for download for academic users directly
from cosmic and for commercial users
through
kayaking
i'm happy to answer all your questions
and i'm sure also is rebecca
thank you very much
thank you dr sanka rebecca for your
informative presentation
we will now start the live q and a
portion of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on the ask
on the far left of your screen we'll
answer as many of your questions as we
have time for
let's get started our first question is
how do you decide which papers to curate
um i can take this one um
so
i'd love to say there was a very
specific formula to it
but really it comes down to the
expertise of our curators um obviously
as i said each of them are responsible
for certain genes and they have
searches in place which
means that they're constantly
downloading papers that are related to
those genes and they'll use a bit of
their own instinct and insight so if
it's a very common gene and very common
mutations are being reported in a paper
maybe they will put that to one side and
focus on something novel that's new that
adds some new insight to our database
that's not to say they wouldn't curate
that paper but it's that kind of
instinct and insight around quality
and more specifically
um there are some minimum requirements
in place for a paper to be included
um there's details about this on our web
pages um under the submissions um page
but it's things um like the minimum
requirement for a sample to be included
and it needs to have full mutation
details provided at either nucleotide or
protein level um and the same um if
they're samples more than one mutation
we need to know which specific mutations
occur together in any given sample
um another interesting thing we do do is
we do accept author submissions and we
won't guarantee that we will curate it
if it's submitted it doesn't need to
meet criteria and it may take a while
but that is is also an aspect that we
have in cosmic and which can also be
found on those submission pages
thank you
next
how does cosmic help users get maximum
value from its data
i'll take that one
um so
the data is the the main databases so we
have uh
multiple additional products that help
interpreting these data so it's not only
about what exchange cancer but also why
and what are the consequences and
what we can do about it
and
we also have uh
help pages i think by the way that's the
to the one of the next questions
showing how to
how to present data
another thing that we are currently
preparing are scripts
to analyze
the data in cosmic
and
they are standard they will be standard
protocols for
getting the answers that
users want to
have answered and if you can suggest
any problems that you are dealing with
what would you like to see
then we will be very grateful for your
feedback on that and we can prepare a
proper software that analyzes the
cosmic data
great thank you
next question
where can i learn how to obtain cosmic
outputs that you are presenting here is
there a training course
um yes i think um we just covered that a
little bit but i just wanted to cover
with part of our science communication
strategy we're exploring how we can be
running some more events um tutorials um
to really add value and to help people
make the most of our data um at the
moment we've not got any of that
strategy in place we're trying to
understand what the biggest needs are
um
but if you follow us on twitter and also
if you sign up
for our mailing list which you can do
when you sign up to cosmic we will be
putting further details out and asking
some more questions around that in
addition we do have tutorials so for
instance with um cosmic 3d which you um
just saw um being presented um we're
going to be doing a launch of
a revitalized version and that will come
with a tutorial video and we'll also be
running an event to talk you through
cosmic 3d in more detail and to try and
understand how to make the most of that
data and we're hoping to do that more
product by product as we go forward so
it's not quite there yet but it is in
the pipeline and we are hoping to
produce more like this and
and as you just heard the more you tell
us about what you need and what you're
looking for the more we can then begin
designing those resources
great thank you
next question what is the breakdown of
adult cancer versus pediatric cancer
representation in cosmic
this is something you can directly
extract from the uh download files i'm
not quite sure if the website can do
that
but as rebecca mentioned uh this is one
of the uh
one of the data points that our curator
gathers so a proposal provider has a
distinction between child and uh and
adults
depending how detailed the information
the paper is but where the
accurate age is given in the paper we
also have that information and as i said
it is
contained in the download files
if you have any
around
because and we'll be
happy to help you with that
great well thank you again dr sanka
rebecca for your time today and your
important research
we would also like to thank labyruts and
our sponsor kaya jen for underwriting
today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event
until next time goodbye
you